で自分に自信があるで聞かれたらあなたは
何て答えますか
私だったらうんって言っちゃいます
44.9%
これは高校生を対象とした調査で明らかに
なった自分に価値を見いだしている日本の
高校生の割合です
なんて微妙な勝ちなんだろうって思いませ
ん
別に高くもないしに低くもないやって
実はこの調査
アメリカ中国韓国のさっ国でも行われまし
た
しかもなんと空さんと黒80%がは結構と
だけだしたんです
日本の44点中と3カ国の80
カルビ違うと思いません
なんでこう町がが顕著に表れたのでしょう
か
日本人の
地震英語で言うする服オフレース飯食い
からああ
今回は16年からのスーッと日本ですん
でして
去年体に飛び出してみちゃった私の視点
からする服をフェイスについて語っていけ
たらなと思います
する服オフレースを持つようになってから
私の実践はもっと持つ楽しくなりました
だからこのスピーチが皆さんのする服オフ
レースを見直すきっかけになれたら嬉しい
です
さてカラダってどんな国なんだろう
皆さん気になりません
からだ文字通り多民族国家です
どこにいても何をしてても毎回英語以外の
言語を見るに入ります時々叶えない以来の
国にいるんじゃないかなぁと思わされる
こともあります
また体には四季があり
雪や桜たくさんのご予約もしれます
さて
眉毛が少し長瀬みたので少しずつ本来に
移っていきますね
正直に言うと私は自分の周りに自分に自信
がない人がいるなあと思ったことがあまり
ありません
だから私は留学に加え日本人に自信が無い
なんていうのは自己師匠の弱さなのによる
マイナスのステーをタイプなだけ
ただのイメージだと思いました
っていう実際体に入ってみたらやっぱり
事実なんだなーって実感しました
日本で座った私が言うんだからマジはあり
ません
体に住んでいる人や現地だった留学生は
とにかくフレンドにせよ非婚選出社交的
この3つのワードが彼らにすごく見えます
これらは全く違う意味を持つワードですが
実は強いつながりがあるんです
自分に自信0-フェイスがあればもっと
フレンドリーにもサポート的にもなれます
服オフィスを待つことが自分は価値のある
人間でいろんなものに挑戦することに
ふさわしい人間だと思えるほどにつながる
んです
私は彼らだって日本と比べ圧倒的に民圧倒
的にみんながする服オフィスを持っている
ように感じました
で
皆さんは授業し自分から発言しますか
発言している方も完全に回転とか神田向き
ですね
巨やはり発言しにくい方が多いんじゃない
かなぁと思います
この日本の傾向を死んだがら体に行き私が
驚いたのは生徒が授業中周りを全く気にせ
ず1番発言していたことです
彼らは常に自分に自信あり自分の発言意見
行動にも自信があるように見えました
皆さん
飲茶業務使いますか
なぜなら海外のアカウントをフォローを
取材しますか
私はインスタグラムが self
confidence を比べる上で
面白い例だと思いました
私の日本人の友人と外国人の友人の
アカウントは全く違います
外国人の友人のアカウントは日本人の友人
のアカウントに比べ
恋の社員神のメインで
時ご視聴ハメ師目でその後自身の魅力に
あふれています
私はホステル不幸プレイスの違いには周り
の環境が影響していると考えます
特に前の褒めの文化の違いです
体では皆が息をするように褒め言葉を賛美
します
その t シャツ可愛いね今日の免許 d
やん
など初めての代から朝の挨拶ますすべてを
目とともにありますこの小さな褒めが
大きな自信につながるんです
英語に自信がなく英語は苦手だった私は体
で頑張れたのは私の
ちょっとはつたない英語
精一杯吠えてくれた友人と先生のおかげ
です
また個性を伸ばす文化の違いはあるんじゃ
ないかなと思います
個性を伸ばすことはセルフィ
コーポレーションを爪での強みにつながり
ます
カラーの授業は
選択授業で自分の得意科目を伸ばせる仕様
になっています
日本のように主力まんべんだけどいう感じ
ではなく個人の興味と杭を深めていくよう
な感じです
また日本には同調圧力というものがあり
みんなと同じいうことが求められ
少しはそのみんなと違っているものは受け
られにくいんです私たちの良くも悪くもは
思うよとする意識は時々個性をつぶして
しまいますこれめちゃめちゃもったいなく
ないですか
自分と違った人がいるからこそ新しい価値
観が生まれ
ちいせーなもっと楽しくなるんです
スコープレースを持つことによるメリット
はたくさんあります小さいメリットで言う
と複数を考えたりメイクをするのを楽しく
なります
そんな中実際に私がする服をプレイステー
を持つようになって感じた一番大きい
メリットは物事を前向きに捉え失敗をすれ
ずに何事にも挑戦しようと思えるように
なったことです
またセルフフェイスに満ち溢れている人は
信用されやすく自然と倍に1勝ちあるん
です
みなさんはもうすでにする飛行機レースを
持ちたいなぁと思い始めてはずです
でもどうやって
これはかなり難しい挑戦です
ここで私自身が弦を弾くオペレーションを
持ってるようになった一つま方法特別に
教えします
まず一つ目は他社と比較しないことです
これは一番大切なことです sns を
見ればどこもかしこも自分よりも魅力的な
人であふれていると思うこともあるかも
しれません
友人が完璧に名て自分を撮っているように
感じることもあると思います
でも決してあなたが踊っていることはあり
山ありません
sns にはもちろん魅力的な人たくさん
います
でもそれはその人の一部分でしかなく賞賛
の床が見えているだけです
そして友人がどれだけ優秀でもあなたがを
とっているなんてことはありません
一人一人が必ず強みを持っています
その強みも勉強やポーじゃなくていいん
ですよ
優しさや教えも愛に強さも立派な強みです
また
自分等
は違う人間簿自分と同じ土俵で支度するの
は見当違いですよ
性格も環境も全く違うはずです私たちが
比較しなくてはいけないのは過去の自分今
の自分
未来の自分です
しかし頭ではわかっていてもそのように
考えるが難しいことですよね
すごくわかります
私も留学中インスタグラムのストーリーを
火で比較し落ち込んだ時期がありました
そんな時友人を急いでくれたのは悪い今日
も家になるくらいならにないようにする
ことです
自分を傷つけるような比較を前にして
逃げることは決して悪いことではありませ
ん
2つ目は自分を褒めることですさきほども
言いました
褒めることは獅子へ繋がります小さい目標
をつくってそれを達成したり何か新しい
ものに挑戦してみたりする不幸スペースを
待つかにはどこにいればあります少し意識
したいつもと違う自分か違うと思うぞふう
に入ってるかもしれません
そのような日を罰人が増えたら
44.9%が倍になる日もそう遠くはない
かもしれません